the jurogan experience when i was in new
york city in uh like the early 90s
there was a ton of dudes who would just
be hanging around pool halls trying to
get games and gambling and they didn't
have any jobs
they slept on park benches they slept
under pool tables damn yeah for the
lovers of [ __ ] billionaires
it wasn't that it's just like they could
kind of barely get by that way and that
was better than a job right they would
rather get by that way barely then
you know wear a suit show up at a
[ __ ] office well they'd be asking
questions would you rather be shooting
pool or jack it off in front of your
camera
it depends on how much you can make
shooting pool
i mean what kind of money are we talking
about
everybody says i would never jerk off in
front of a camera you wouldn't jerk off
in front of a camera for 89 billion
dollars yeah you would you'd be like oh
wait i'll jack up the camera for 80 000.
right you'd be like
bro i'm telling you right ready right
now [ __ ] i'm saying that yeah for 89
dollars just guys you do it for
89.00 the value of semen for uh a live
us president and obama's was the most
what
did you get on ebay
imagine if michelle left barack and he
just started selling his sperm i'm
saying
he's just slang and [ __ ]
if you hadn't like if you're a famous
guy if you're a famous guy like any like
the rock if the rock wanted to sell us
come see how much he gets
damn
imagine just imagine
just imagine i'm not saying you should
buy it
i'm not saying you should i don't
support this in any way but imagine a
world look if we can imagine nazis yeah
we can imagine a world where the rock
sales has come
what's the price of nut though
he can only do two today
who's evaluating to being like this is
pretty good the markets same as
sotheby's like how about they buy a
painting uncut gyms and cut gyms right
like how much can i sell an ounce of
nuts yeah man if you want to see a
[ __ ] car auction at those uh
barrett jackson car auctions we have a
1940s
it's all about demand
we got one of the rocks nuts from 2017.
that was a good year
that's a good year that's like yeah
signed the ross
he signs the [ __ ] test tube it's like
they open the jar it's all [ __ ] you
know like glas wood dry ice steam
by the rocks
cryogenically frozen the rocks come
that's worth that's worth a million
dollars so in my mind
100 it's a million dollars at least
we're being conservative here okay
if the rock can jerk off twice a day he
makes two million dollars a day minimum
damn that's a check
dog yeah i mean you're trying to sell
your catalog 60 million a year a month
rather than 60 million a month
many times i jacked off this week
literally imagine if the rock jerked off
twice a day
and sold it
and he made billions of dollars
elon musk
that's what i want to know
who will take out all these goddamn kids
though
does he have to give us a percentage of
that to child support
right
that's how they get it that's like the
lottery right yeah
that's crazy because you technically are
the father like just because you didn't
experience this pleasure
that is your child right
like they would appeal to you on a moral
level like that is your child yeah it's
your child just like in that one movie
uh she hate me with anthony mackie when
he [ __ ] all them hoes when he was
giving his sperm out you said you seen
that i didn't you got to watch that he
was well then i would make sure it might
come as spoiled first like it's got to
be dead and then throw hot sauce on it
isn't that what drake did
didn't he throw hot sauce in his in his
condom yeah that was like the room
rattle up is real but yeah of course
it's not real okay it's like the stephen
cigar
story from ukraine like just because
it's not real doesn't mean it's not
funny and you shouldn't tell it
[Laughter]
oh that's awesome so you're gonna sell a
bunch of fake dope fake nut oh yeah like
like you know smashing base on oregano
as we no no no you can't do that you got
to be a man you got to be a man be a man
you're going to sell your real [ __ ] and
as you get older it's like you know it's
more precious because you don't have as
much
it's like diamonds it's like the beers
they keep that [ __ ] squirreled away for
a reason yeah you get some of that frank
thomas from new jennings you'll be all
right
so might come on nft [ __ ]
yeah comes only valuable when a woman
wants it right right which is like how
much time do you like at what point in
time like you can keep it
often enough come
on yeah
there's certain people that can do it
that's right that's right it's a select
few right
you're in that you're in that group bro
if a woman could show an nft of her
[ __ ]
like how how many women can make money
doing that there's a lot
i know i know it's gross but it's the
same thing as who's buying income like
what are people doing what are people
doing [ __ ] will buy that [ __ ]
what are people doing they're distracted
by all kinds of nonsense i mean that's
crazy
people out there because that would be
like one of the greatest heists ever if
you could get barack obama's calm wow
that's what i was saying that's what i'm
saying so [ __ ] horrible
it sounds terrible it does but if i mean
imagine a world where that wasn't a
moral quandary it wasn't a giant issue
he's sorry michelle yeah sorry i'm not
saying it's going to happen
but that's not going to be like [ __ ]
this
look and you could take a [ __ ] that
ain't guaranteed your kid gonna be a
president but it might be a crackhead in
a pool hall you dig what i'm saying yes
truth
true
most likely who's elsa obama uh most
likely you're most likely not going to
be a president like most likely there's
no way he'd be a president right like
what [ __ ] person the president is
like the number one least likely job you
would ever have
right though
it's only one of them
yeah
if you said like like like there's no
guarantee that if the only problem is
the last name if he gets the last name
it's obama get the last name any like
kennedy's
yeah that kennedy last name you know
there was jfk there was bobby kennedy
you know how many bushes we've had i'm
shooting my nut out there for money i
want to be anonymous i don't want to
know them about punking [ __ ] them kids i
mean there are sperm bodies i guess they
already do this they're they're
[ __ ] you take that [ __ ] you
bought the nut you take what come with
it
you bought it you bought this monster
you broke it you bought it yeah that's
what i would have to do i had to sign a
[ __ ] uh indiana yeah yeah
a nut disclosure agreement
[Laughter]
oh my god that's perfect
imagine if you just jerked off into a
cup for a living like that's your move
and you realize like listen i can make a
thousand dollars a load i don't have to
talk to nobody right i just have to jerk
i'm [ __ ] a job
ma i mean
your jizz is worth at least a thousand
dollars but i had to take a week or two
off because you know what i'm saying i
ain't going to [ __ ] the hoes
i know that's going to be a problem
clarity is above you you have to decide
how much money you want to make in a
week right you don't have to [ __ ] do
it every day but if if you thought about
like what if there was an ingredient if
you wanted a child
and there was an ingredient that you can
add to an egg that would make a person
100 of the time
how much was how much is that worth damn
maybe we could make it synthetic you'll
need real nuts bro that's how the robots
take over sure
that's that's that's how the next
version of humans with no emotions take
over